foreign
City story that corrupt Town yeah you
said we had something we do we do we do
here you go new developments tonight in
the ktru u11 investigation of the coffee
City Police Department last week we
uncovered the town of 250 people has 50
officers on the force and more than half
of those officers have tainted past now
Jeremy Rogowski reports the coffee City
our new our new Stossel yes Jeremy
Rogowski are Stossel in Waiting Stossel
Jr yeah Council has suspended hey you
know what his name's Jeremy Rogowski
Juniors Jr let's call Junior Rogowski Jr
Jr police
[Music]
Chief John J Portillo is off the job for
30 days
Council voted to suspend him pending an
independent investigation into what we
found khu 11 investigates revealed how
Portillo routinely hired officers who
had been suspended demoted terminated or
dishonorably discharged from their
previous law enforcement jobs for a wide
range of misconduct or even criminal
charges
we also reported on a profanity filled
rant the chief launched at a Harris
County Constable while he was working an
extra security job in Houston and we
uncovered how Portillo failed to list on
his job application this active DWI case
out of Florida in which he failed that
was crazy yeah from the looks of it you
weren't being truthful
on the application to which you hold the
job this day
Chief yeah
Chief Sir
I mean but that's not what it is I'm not
not being truthful
I'm just not telling the whole truth
I just I put down everything that was in
my mind when I filled out my application
the best of my knowledge our
investigation also revealed how coffee
City warrant officers didn't even work
in coffee city that was crazy they're
working remote in Houston yeah and on
commission on commission they stayed
home in Houston spending their time on
the phone calling people with
outstanding traffic warrants and
collecting failure to appear fines after
week question that's got to be like the
best gig in the world because like it's
one thing to be like a you know
collection agency and you're like you
owe 58 bucks from you know Spectrum from
four years ago people would be like get
but that's got to be the easiest
collections gig because it's like yeah
listen uh you're gonna go to jail or you
can give me 200 bucks like that's got to
be easy I'll go to jail
sorry
or to about the program is that legal
I believe so
the chief suspended the warrant division
we got a hold of Portillo on them call
center merch my line would be do you
know who judge such and such is yeah
he's the guy who signs all the warrants
for us
foreign
there is something extremely unlikable
about just him right like something
about his demeanor oh the chief yeah the
Portillo guy yeah off-putting about him
yeah
declined to comment about the suspension
and that's not the only shake-up in the
coffee City ranks Sergeant Cody Welch
resigned from the Department we don't
know why well yeah because he went to
WWE yeah he did find a comment Jeremy
Rogowski KHOU 11 invest